في واشنطن قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطون بلانكن ان الاله العسكريه الروسيه
باتت في مازقنا الان وكان منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي قال ان بوتين لجا الى
شركه فاجنر بسبب الصعوبات في تجنيد الروس
في القتال في اوكرانيا واضاف كيربي في
احاطه له ان شركه فاجنر تعاني من خسائر
بشريه فادحه وفقدت الاسبوع الماضي نحو
الفا من مقاتلها انا اشترت اسلحه من كوريا
الشماليه لتعزيز مقاتلها في اوكرانيا
عقابيه جديده ضد بعض
ضموا الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس
ما الذي يجري في باخموت بين تاكيد
الاوكراني بالصيطره عليها
والروايه اخرى مضاده روسيه
كر وفر حول بخموط
محاور الهجوميه من شمال بخبوط وجنوب بخموط
وحتى من الشرق ولكن اليوم كمدينه بحد
ذاتها لم تسقط وهذا امر يعني تظهره
الدلائل التكتيكيه على الارض هذه المدينه
مهمه
قبل ان كانت مهمه اليوم اقل اهميه يعني
عندما نتحدث عن
مدينتين سقطتها مخموط كانت الخلفيه
اللوجستيه اليوم مخموت هي المدخل الى
كرامه تورسك ولكن تراجعت اهميتها بعد سقوط
الزيون لكنها معركه شخصيه وخاصه لممول
شركه
لانه يريد اثبات ان هناك همم فيجنر هي
اكثر من الجيش الروسي وهو يطالب ان ياخذ
يعني ترتيب معين وشرعيه معينه من حكومه
الروسيه وخاصه من الرئيس بوتين خاصه اذا
تحقق هذا الامر بالاضافه سلمى الى همم
كونسون التعويض في محمود فقط لموضوع
المعنويات وموضوع عدم التراجع وعلى ذكر
عميد الياس شركه فاجنر الى اي درجه همم
ترى همم المقاربه العمليه
لهذه الشركه هي مقاربه همم عسكريه مجديه
على الارض في ظل حديث امريكا ايضا عن
ضروره استهدافها في العقوبه
يعني العقوبات شيء معين قد يكون تاثيرها
اقل لانها رمزيه قد تكون لانها التمويل
ياتي من الداخل والسلاح كما قلت في
التقرير ياتي من كوريا الشماليه هذه
الشركه بالقانون الروسي ليست موجوده لا
يعترف فيها لها عمليات متعدده خارج حتى
روسيا من سوريا الى غرب افريقيا هي شيء
مهم لانها تقاتل بطريقه مختلفه ولكن اليوم
هذا الاستثمار الكبير في بطوط هو كبير جدا
مقابل الارباح التي قد تاتي انها تثبت
الكثير من العسكر همم الروسي بدل ان يكون
في جبهه اخرى مختلفه ههه شكرا لك عميد
الياس حنا حدثتنا من بيروت